R
WITH SOME SELF DEFENSE AS YOU
DON'T WANT TO MISS.
AND SINCE JOE BIDEN TOOK OFFICE,
HAMMER CONTAINS WEEK BOUNCING
FROM ONE CRISIS TO THE NEXT ANY
OF THE COVID-19 PANDEMIC,
MASSIVE INFLATION, AFGHANISTAN,
RUSSIAN INVADES UKRAINE IN THE
ENERGY CRISIS, AND YET ALL ALONG
THE WAY, IT IS THE LITTLE GUYS
IN THE SEEM TO GET SCREWED THE
MOUSE AND YOU KNOW, THE
HAVE-NOTS IN SOCIETY AND WHY ARE
WE ALWAYS LEFT HOLDING THE BAG
AFTER ALL OF THE CONNECTED HAVES
DO ALL OF THE DAMAGE IT AND THE
HAVES OF THE POWERBROKER REALLY
DO SEEM TO MAKE THE RULES THE
REST OF US ARE FORCED TO LIVE
UNDER IN THIS KIND OF GOT ME
THINKING, THIS SOUNDS AWFUL LOT
LIKE AN OLIVE GARDEN DOESN'T
HAVE US CHECK THE DEFINITION ALL
YOUR COURTING TO MERRIAM-WEBSTER
IT'S A GOVERNMENT WHICH A SMALL
GROUP EXERCISES CONTROL
ESPECIALLY FOR CORRUPTED
PURPOSES HAD UN, WINNER WINNER
CHICKEN DINNER AND ARE WE LIVING
UNDER THIS NOW AND WE BEING
GOVERNED BY ITS SMALL GROUP OF
POWERFUL ELITES TO MAKE SPECIAL
RULES FOR THEMSELVES USING APPS,
MAKING A SEPARATE SET OF RULES
FOR EVERYONE ELSE AND YOU KNOW
US, HAVE-NOTS, IS SOME EVIDENCE
THAT MAY HELP US ANSWER THIS
QUESTION RIGHT HERE PRETTY JUST
THIS WEEK THE PRESIDENT BLACK,
NO DOUBT HAVE ONE OF THE LARGEST
INVESTMENT FIRMS IN THE U.S. WAS
QUOTED IN BLOOMBERG YOU TALKING
ABOUT THE HAVE-NOTS WITHOUT
SAYING THAT THIS IS JIM, FOR THE
FIRST TIME, THIS GENERATION IS
GOING TO GO INTO US A STORE AND
NOT BE ABLE TO GET WHAT THEY
WANTED WE HAVE A VERY ENTITLED
GENERATION THIS NEVER HAD TO
SACRIFICE REALLY AND I WANT TO
ADD TO THAT AND SO TO BE CLEAR,
HE THINKS THAT YOU ARE ENTITLED
FOR NOT WANTING TO PAY $10 FOR
GAS OR DEAL WITH FOOD SHORTAGES
AND SEE THERE'S NO PROBLEMS AT
ALL WITH A BLOCK WALK GUY PAYING
FOR $10 PER GALLON FOR GAS HE'S
HAVE.
AND WE KNOW HOW HE PAYS WE GUESS
AND HERE'S MORE, JUST A FEW
WEEKS AGO, NEW YORK CITY LIFTED
THE VACCINE MANDATES FOR ALL
PERFORMERS GIVING UNVACCINATED
PROFESSIONAL ATHLETES ON THE
RELAX TO PLAY HOME GAMES AGAIN
BUT WHAT IF YOUR CITY WORKER OR
A POLICE OFFICER BEING FORCED
OUT OF THE JOB BECAUSE OF A
MANDATE WILL CLEARLY, THERE HAVE
NOT READ.
>> AT THIS TIME, WE ARE NOT
REVEALING FULL GOING TO BRING
BACK THOSE LARGE NUMBER BUT THEY
WERE HIRED WITH THE
UNDERSTANDING THEY HAD TO BE
VACCINATED WILL FOCUS ON THE
SCIENCE AND WE WILL DO WHAT IS
RIGHT AND MAKE SURE THAT WE ARE
HEALTHY AND BE HEALTHY IS NOT
ONLY PHYSICALLY HEALTHY,
ECONOMIC HEALTHY.
I CONSIDER THIS AN ANALYSIS THAT
I MADE AND HAPPY WITH MY
DECISION.
DAN: I JUST HATE THESE GUYS, SO
PEOPLE LIKE MAYOR ADAMS AND
THESE PRO ATHLETES, THEY ARE ALL
OF THE HABITS COME TOGETHER
POLICE OFFICERS ARE MAKING 55
AND $60000 A YEAR NOW
UNEMPLOYED, THAT CLEARLY YOU
KNOW THE HAVE-NOTS.
AND WHAT ABOUT THE TEACHERS
UNIONS AND WERE JUST LOOKING OUT
FOR THE KIDS AT SAFETY DURING
COVID-19 OR SO THEY SAID IN A
NEW REPORT SHOWS THAT TEACHERS
UNIONS WERE CLOSELY WITH THE CDC
AND TO DETERMINE WHEN THEY
THOUGHT THAT IT WOULD BE SAFER
BECAUSE OF GO BACK TO SCHOOL AND
THEY'VE NEVER BEEN INVOLVED TO
THIS DEGREE IN THE PAST AND TALK
ABOUT A GROUP OF CONNECTED TO
HAVE HAVES CAN YOU CALL THE CDC
YOU DO THAT I DON'T THINK SO AND
I HOPE YOU LIVE IN CHICAGO IN
YOUR CONCERNED ABOUT RISING
CRIME, TOO BAD, YOU HAVE NOT
INSIDE YOUR MOUTH, YOU AND THE
REST OF THE HAVE-NOTS, YOU'D
BETTER JUST YOU KNOW FIND A WITH
IT.
BUT DON'T SWEAT IT BECAUSE IF
YOU HAVE, SHE REPORTEDLY
PROTECTED BY A SPECIAL SECURITY
SQUAD WITH DOZENS OF POLICE
OFFICERS, CRIME PROBLEM, BUT SHE
WORRIED ABOUT.
THEN THERE'S ALL OF THE HAVES IN
CONGRESS YOU KNOW THE ZEROS WHO
WERE SUPPOSED TO SERVE AS A
REPRESENTATIVES LED BY THE WAY
BY THE DISGRACEFUL NANCY PELOSI
WILL HERE'S A LIST OF EVERYTHING
THEY'RE BEHOLDEN TO COME I'M
SORRY, I MEAN EXEMPT FROM, SORRY
THAT WAS A SLIP THERE AND IF YOU
REMEMBER IN CONGRESS, IF YOU
DON'T WANT TO GET THE VACCINE,
DON'T WORRY IF YOU WANT TO BE
ABLE TO TRADE IN THE STOCK
MARKET, REGARDLESS OF THE FACT
THAT YOU CONTROL ALL OF THE
LEGISLATION THE BASICALLY
IMPACTS THE MARKET, GO FOR IT.
YOU DON'T WANT TO SHOW UP FOR
WORK COMING ON ABOUT IT REMOTELY
EVEN THOUGH THE PANDEMIC IS
LARGELY OVER, NO PROBLEM.
YOU KNOW WHEN HE CARE HEATER,
FOR YOUR FAMILY WHAT WE HAVE TO,
YOU DON'T HAVE TO YOUR A HALF
AND SOME OF THE HAVES ON CAPITOL
HILL ACCOMPLISHING FOR US, THE
HAVE-NOTS PRETTY REMEMBER THE
VOTE TO PRINT IS TRILLIONS OF
STIMULUS DAUGHTER STILL BOOST
THE ECONOMY, SUPPOSEDLY HELP US
DURING THE PANDEMIC WILL CHECK
ON THIS HEADLINE, THIS IS NO
MUCH IT HELPED US.
WE ARE FACED AND FACING AN
INFLATION TAX BECAUSE THE CREDIT
A VOTE LOAD OF MONOPOLY MONEY
AND 52 YEARS, PLEASE HELP
HELPING, TURNS OUT THE
HAVE-NOTS, PAYING THE BILL AGAIN
AND HAVES VOTED TO PRINT ALL OF
THE MONEY BAD IS IN, DON'T
MISUNDERSTAND, WHILE THE ACTIONS
COST YOU MORE, THESE POWERFUL
ELITES LIKE HUNTER BIDEN, THEY
ARE DOING A OKAY, ACHING
MILLIONS ON THEIR CORRUPTIONS
PRETTY.
>> THIS NOT RUSSIAN
DISINFORMATION WITH HIS OR HER
ARTIFACTS IT BACK TO BUY BANK
RECORDS SO COMPANY THAT WAS
EFFECTIVELY ARMED THE CHINESE
GOVERNMENT TRANSFERRED
$1 MILLION IN NOVEMBER OF 2017,
TWO COMPANY HUNTER BIDEN
MANAGING IS INVESTING IN.
>> IN CASE YOU'RE UNDER THE
MISTAKEN DISBELIEF THAT THIS IS
ONLY HAPPENING IN THE UNITED
STATES, THE HAVE-NOTS IN
GERMANY, THEIR CITIZENS RIGHT
NOW ARE BRACING FOR ELECTRICITY
BLACKOUTS DUE TO NATURAL GAS
RATIONING BECAUSE THAT HOUSE IN
GERMANY A WHILE AGO DECIDED TO
STAY DEPENDENT ON RUSSIAN ENERGY
AND SO LIKE WE WERE NOT WERE
GOOD ABOUT THIS EITHER THE, WE
KNEW IT, CHECK OF THIS REPORT
FROM CBS, FOUR YEARS AGO.
>> AENEAS CONTROLLED BY RUSSIA
TO FOR PRESIDENT TRUMP CONFIRMED
THE FEARS BY USING THE NATO
STAGE TO CRITICIZE ALLIES AND
BLESSING GERMANY OVER A NATURAL
GAS PIPELINE DEAL WITH RUSSIA.
>> IS REALLY SAD WHEN GERMANY
MESA MASSIVE OIL AND GAS DEAL
WITH RUSSIA WHERE IT SHOULD BE
GUARDED AGAINST RUSSIA AND
GERMANY GOES OUT IT PAYS
MILLIONS AND MILLIONS OF DOLLARS
A YEAR.
REPORTER: GERMAN OFFICIAL DENIED
A CONTROVERSIAL MORE STREAM TO
PIPELINE WILL ALLOW RUSSIA TO
HAVE UNDUE INFLUENCE OVER THEIR
COUNTRY.
>> FOR EVERYBODY OUT THERE BY
THE WAY STILL DOUBTING THAT THIS
IS NOT ON PURPOSE TO BRING IN A
NEW ORDER TO THE WORLD OR
WHATEVER THEY WANT TO CALL IT,
THIS WAS JUST A LITTLE BIT AGO
THE WORLD GOVERNMENT SUMMIT.
>> THE TITLE OF THE SESSION, ARE
WE READY FOR A NEW WORLD ORDER
SEE WHEN ARE YOU READY, I'M NOT,
THIS NEW WORLD ORDER CELLS LIKE
CRAP TO ME IS SOMETHING REALLY
SOCKS AND SOME HOUSES OUT FOR
YOU, ARE YOU ENJOYING LIVING
UNDER THE RULES WORKING UNDER
TH